>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I'm Stephanie
Marcus from the Science, Technology,
and Business division
here at the Library.
I want to welcome you to
Cassini's Grand Finale.
It sounds sort of like a
symphonic piece, and it probably is
with a loud crash at the end.
Let's see.
We are really lucky to have one of
the Cassini team members here today.
So close to Cassini's demise
which will be a week
from Friday, the 15th.
Conor Nixon is a space
scientist from NASA Goddard.
He is originally from Belfast
and was educated in the UK.
He is, he was, he earned
a BA in Natural Sciences
from the University of Cambridge.
A Master of Science
in Radio Astronomy
from the University of Manchester.
And finally his PhD
in Planetary Science
from the University of Oxford.
He's been with the Cassini message,
mission since his graduate days,
and he is a, he's had
many awards at NASA.
The latest was the
Robert H Goddard Award
for Exceptional Achievement
in Science.
We have 13 years of Cassini
observations, highlights,
and the grand finale to get through.
So please help me welcome
Conor Nixon to the Library.
[ Applause ]
>> Conor Nixon: Thank
you, Stephanie,
for such a gracious introduction.
And thank you for the
invitation to come here.
I'm really excited to be here
at the Library of Congress.
My first time in this building.
And to address you all and
convey the excitement that I have
for this mission that I've
worked on for more than 20 years.
It's now coming to a dramatic end.
I'm sure some of you have heard next
week this is coming up really fast.
So today I just want to talk about
some of the exciting highlights
that we've had from
the mission so far.
It's been a great voyage
of discovery.
And then take you right up
to the present day and talk
about what we've done in the
last few months and weeks.
And what's going to happen
in the next eight days.
So first thing I just
want to introduce Cassini.
So Cassini is actually the Cassini,
we call it the Cassini-Huygens
mission.
It's actually two spacecraft and
they're - one was produced by NASA.
This is the Cassini orbiter.
Which is currently in
orbit around Saturn.
And then there was a
probe which was built
by the European Space
Agency named Huygens.
This was named after a Dutch
scientist who was the discoverer
of the giant moon of
Saturn called Titan.
And this was attached to Cassini.
Shortly after it arrived in the
Saturn system, the end of 2004,
it was released and this
became the first probe
to land on the moon, Titan.
And that gave us a
whole different insight
into what was going on on Titan.
That mission was short in duration.
It was just a two-and-a-half
hour descent to the surface.
And then that probe, the Huygens
probe, its batteries were used up.
But since then the Cassini
orbiter has continued
with its 12 instruments to give
us the science that we've had.
So how did Cassini get to Saturn?
This was launched back in 1997.
And the Cassini spacecraft was so
big that we couldn't just push it
on a direct trajectory
all the way to Saturn.
So we had to use a trick.
And the trick that we used
was to get a slingshot
from some of the inner planets.
So Cassini actually flew by Venus
a couple times, by the Earth.
And then finally it ringed
its way out to Jupiter
and got its final slingshot maneuver
to give it that extra boost,
that extra kick to get it
all the way out to Saturn.
So after a seven-year cruise,
Cassini reached Saturn
in July 1st, 2004.
And then it burned its rocket
engines for about 70 minutes.
And it braked and slowed itself
down so it could go into orbiter
around Saturn and begin its voyage
around Saturn and the moons.
On the way of course we were able to
get glimpses of Venus and Jupiter.
And this proved to be very useful
for us because we were actually able
to test out all our systems.
And we got a lot of great science
actually out of Jupiter as well.
This was the launch.
It was almost 20 years ago.
And it was a fantastic launch.
It was a night launch.
I was lucky enough to be there.
I was still a student at the time
but it was a really exciting time
to wish Cassini well on its way.
And then as you can see, seven
years later, it burned its rockets
to go into orbit at Saturn.
So the Cassini mission
was originally designed
to have a four-year
lifetime from 2004 to 2008.
But 2008 came around, the spacecraft
was still in robust good health.
Every system was working.
We still had half our fuel left,
so we continued the mission
for two more years to see
the equinox at Saturn.
Then at that point, we were
extended for another seven years
to go all the way to 2017.
And this was calculated to
be the end of the mission
when we've used up all our fuel.
And there's nothing
left in the tanks.
So we have to end the
mission at that point.
And this has been really
great because as you can see
in this graphic here, Saturn
has very long seasons.
So Saturn takes 30 years
to go around the sun.
And so it's 30 times as long
as the year that we have.
And that means that its seasons are
about seven-and-a-half
Earth years in length.
So just to see one season,
you have to be there
for seven-and-a-half years.
Well, Cassini has been
in orbit for 13 years,
so that's almost two full seasons.
And that's given us the chance to
see the spring and the fall reverse
between the Northern
and the Southern hemisphereon
Saturn and also its moons.
So here's where we are today.
We're right at the end.
And I really love this graphic.
There's a lot of information
packed in here.
And this really summarizes what
we've done in the entire mission.
So at the top, you can see
the orbits that we've had.
The shape of the orbits.
As Cassini has gone from more
of an equatorial orbit of Saturn
to more of a polar orbit.
The orbits have tilted up and down
so that we can see different things.
The, the large yellow
circles you see
up at the top half are
these Titan flybys.
So these are flybys of
Saturn's largest moon, Titan.
And then below that you can
see flybys of Enceladus.
A moon which I'm going
to talk about.
And some of the other
[inaudible] satellites.
Saturn has 62 known
satellites at last count.
And Cassini has discovered
several of those new one.
So a lot of, a lot of satellites
ranging from very large.
Titan's the largest,
5000 kilometers in size.
Down to very small ones,
just a couple of kilometers.
And at the bottom here, you
can see the seasons changing
in the Northern hemispherefrom
winter to spring and now to summer.
And right over on the
very right-hand, sorry.
Right around the very right-hand
side, you can see these,
I don't know if I can
use my pointer.
But here you can see these
what we call our final orbits.
So we have 22 of three final orbits,
and we're right now
approaching our very last orbit.
Just some great facts
and figures here.
I'm not going to talk
about all of these.
But Cassini's traveled
billions of miles.
And the thing that I find the
most exciting is the number
of scientific publications, nearly
4000 at the time this was written,
scientific publications have
come out of this mission.
So it's really been
a fantastic mission.
So I'm going to start by showing
you a few highlights of the,
of the Cassini mission during
the 13 years that we've had.
I'm going to begin with one
of Saturn's smaller moons,
and this is Enceladus.
This is 500 kilometers in, in size.
Or three hundred miles.
This is what the moon
Enceladus looks like.
It's named after one of the
Titans from mythology as some
of its sibling moons are.
And you can see that Enceladus,
it's a very bright object.
It's not covered in sand or dirt.
It looks like an icy material.
It's one of the brightest,
most reflective objects we have
in the solar system, almost
looks like a billiard ball.
And if you look towards the
bottom of the image here,
you'll see these blue
cracks on the surface here.
And there are four of these
long streaks or cracks.
And Cassini has been, Cassini caught
the very first view of these cracks.
And shortly afterwards, we were able
to discover something very
dramatic about Enceladus.
So as Cassini flew by Enceladus,
we discovered that it was
disturbing Saturn's magnetic field.
And you could see here in this image
that these magnetic field lines
which should be shooting right past
Enceladus were being deflected.
And this was an indication that
something was going on here.
And in fact, when Cassini turned its
heat-sensing cameras on Enceladus,
we could see that these cracks which
appeared to be these blue streaks
in the, to the visible cameras were
in fact glowing [inaudible] heat
that were tens of, of degrees warmer
than the cold, cold background.
So this was a really
exciting indication
that there was something unique
about the [inaudible]
polar area of Enceladus.
When Cassini turned its cameras back
toward the sun, we were finally able
to see what was really
going on here.
In fact, these cracks
on the South pole
of Enceladus are shooting
material out into space
like fountains or geysers.
Just like Old Faithful.
Some people on the project like
to call these a Cold Faithful.
So because unlike the, the Earth, of
course this material is much colder.
It's, we believe it's water
that is shooting out into space.
But it's instantly
turned into ice crystals.
These are shooting for
tens or hundreds of miles
out into space all the time.
So you can see looking
back towards the sun,
these jets which are
not easily visible.
You can see them with the
sunlight reflecting through them.
So this is showing us that Enceladus
is one of the very few places
in the solar system
that's actually an active,
geologically active world.
And we're very excited to discover
this and to find out some more
about what's going on here.
So just some other
images of the plumes here.
We can see that these four, four
predominant plumes are tracing
out the four cracks that
we have on the South pole.
So what do we think
is going on here?
It appears that there's liquid water
buried somewhere inside Enceladus.
And this moon is kept from
freezing solid into a block of ice
by the tidal forces that are, that
are kind of kneading it like a ball
of dough by Saturn itself.
So as the moon goes around
Saturn in its elliptical orbit,
it experiences stressed and
compression and tension which keep,
keep it warm inside
and allow the water
to remain liquid under the surface.
And of course the surface on
the outside is frozen solid.
But there's enough water inside,
and there's enough pressure
that periodically, as the
moon goes around Saturn,
it's venting water out into space.
And this is turning into
these geysers that we see.
So here you can see tiny little
black dot right in the middle.
This is Enceladus.
And what's going on here, it's,
it's actually creating its own ring
as it goes around Saturn.
And this is what we call
the E ring, E for Enceladus.
And it's, it's trailing all
this ice material behind it.
You can see here that it's
actually making a kind of a wake,
like a darker wake where it's
plowed through its own ring.
So as it repeatedly
goes around Saturn,
it creates what we
call a [inaudible]
or basically a donut
or icy material.
And this is spreading
out in all directions.
And as it comes back around,
it's actually making like a wake
as it plows back through
its own material.
And these jets are shooting
material out in all directions.
And you can actually
see some of these jets
which are shooting the material out.
Some of the material
goes ahead of Enceladus.
It speeds up as it
goes towards Saturn.
And some of it trails
further behind.
So Enceladus is really this little
500-kilometer-size moon is creating
a cloud that's bigger
than Saturn itself.
So another look inside
Enceladus here.
This is what we think
is going on inside.
We think that it's a, a rocky core,
but then it's surrounded
by this blue layer.
You can see indicated here which
is where the liquid water is.
And on top of this we
have the ice shell.
Now this is exciting not just as
a natural geological phenomenon.
This could be potentially
even more exciting than that.
Because on the Earth, we know
that at the bottom of the sea bed,
right where the volcanic vents
are in the Mid-Atlantic Ridges,
there's a lot of life which
actually likes to congregate there.
And if the core of Enceladus is
indeed warm, and it's surrounded
by this liquid ocean, this could
actually be a similar environment.
And this is really exciting
because this gives the potential
that there could have been life
evolved here inside Enceladus.
This is the deep ocean,
Mid-Atlantic Ridges on the Earth.
You can see here that these
are geologically active.
And these create a whole ecosystem
of life surrounding these.
And right now we can't see
that far down inside Enceladus.
All we have to see is
these plumes of material
which are shooting out into space.
But this is kind of like a free
sample and Cassini has been able
to fly repeatedly through
these plumes.
First, we didn't go too close.
But eventually we got down to
just going a few tens of miles
above the surface and
shooting the spacecraft
through these curtains of material.
And using an instrument
onboard Cassini
to actually measure the material.
And we found some really fascinating
things about the material.
That it's not just water.
In fact, it contains
organic substances,
methane and ethane molecules.
There's also salt containing
potassium and sodium grains.
And there's even larger
organic pieces.
So there's now a huge amount of
excitement that's been generated
by Cassini to say, "Let's go
back to Enceladus someday.
Let's send another mission."
But with different
instruments this time.
We'll have instruments that can
actually go through these plumes
and maybe look for
any evidence of life.
Any traces of biological material
which Cassini was never
designed to find.
Because we didn't, we
did not have any clue
that we were going
to find these jets.
So this is like a, a free
sample from the interior
which is shooting out into space.
And in fact, Enceladus is
not the only moon either
that has liquid water inside.
Cassini has now shown evidence
that all four of these larger moons
of Saturn are warm enough
and close enough to Saturn
that they've maintained
a water layer inside.
Including Titan, which I'm
going to talk about shortly.
Mimas, we nicknamed this one the
Death Star for obvious reasons.
It's got that, that look to
it; that mean look to it.
And Dione which is one
of the other inner moons.
And we believe that all these moons
have a liquid water layer inside.
And, and who knows
what's going on inside.
So this is really exciting
that we've discovered what
we call these ocean worlds
in the outer solar system.
And these may now be our best
chance of life outside the Earth.
So Titan is Saturn's largest moon.
I've already alluded to this.
And this was a really exciting
[inaudible] to discover.
We had the Huygens
probe which descended
to the surface in January 2005.
But it wasn't until later that
year that we were able to make some
of the most dramatic discoveries.
And in fact, something
that was long suspected
but we never had the chance to look
at before given its
thick, hazy atmosphere.
Was that there's material that's
raining down on the surface.
In fact, Titan is the only
moon in the solar system
that has an atmosphere,
a substantial atmosphere.
We have planets that
have atmospheres,
but Titan is the only moon
that has an atmosphere.
All the other moons appear, just you
can see all the way to the surface.
And on, and on Titan's atmosphere,
the action of sunlight acting
on its methane atmosphere,
creates complex molecules.
And in the colder polar regions,
these are actually condensing
and raining down onto the surface.
So this is rainfall, but
not as we have on the Earth.
Not water rainfall.
This is methane rainfall.
And Cassini was the first
to see these lakes and seas
on the north pole of Titan.
So this, these are remarkable.
These lakes and seas are about
the same size as the Great Lakes
that we have in North America.
So this largest lake is
comparable in size to Lake Superior
and this is containing
billions of gallons
of hydrocarbons of
methane and ethane.
So these would be like
your liquid natural gas.
Just seas of this material.
Cassini also discovered that Titan
has dune fields near the equator.
But again, these dune fields are
not the sand dunes that we would see
on the Earth made up
of silicate material.
These are dune fields
made up of little organic,
dried-up organic pieces
kind of like,
almost like miniature
chips, chips of plastic.
This, this would be like Titan's
atmosphere creating a smog,
and organic smog somewhat similar
to the, the smogs that are created
by vehicle fumes on the Earth.
We have these, you know,
famous Los Angeles smogs.
And Titan's doing something
similar but in a natural way.
And these little particles are
coming down on the surface.
And then they're getting
blown around by the winds
and creating thousands
of miles of dune fields.
Again, organic material, but this,
this time not liquid,
[inaudible] solid.
Titan has some small mountains.
Possibly some of these
are actively volcanic.
It's difficult for us to tell
because of this thick atmosphere.
And of course clouds.
And when the Huygens probe was
able to descend to the surface,
land on the surface, it could see
that there was dried
up rivers and seas.
That showed us that
maybe these organic lakes
and seas had been more
extensive in the past.
And now they had retreated
towards the polar regions.
But in the past, they may have
encompassed the entire planet
or much of the, the lower latitudes.
And when these first
pictures came back,
this is actually from the surface.
This, this image here is
from the surface of Titan.
There's a little icy boulders
that are maybe just a few inches
or tens of inches in size.
And when these first pictures
came back, the first reaction
out of the jet propulsion
laboratory was,
"Have we mixed this up with Mars?
Because this looks like Mars."
But this really was
the surface of Titan.
And these little boulders
are not rocks
as they would be on
the surface of Mars.
But these are icy, icy boulders.
You can see here the
magnificent imagery
that the Huygens probe
was able to take.
As it floated down, serenely down to
the surface over a couple of hours.
Actually getting, getting,
getting lower
and lower here from 150 kilometers.
You can't see anything.
You're still in the haze.
And then as you descend 30
kilometers, 8 kilometers,
1.5 kilometers and down
to a few hundred meters.
You can see this magnificent vista
never seen before of this moon.
Back in 1980, the Voyager
spacecraft flew by
but wasn't able to see the surface.
Didn't have the right
cameras onboard.
But finally we're able to see the
surface and see these mountains
and carved river channels
on the surface of Titan.
So Titan is the only place other
than the Earth that you could go to
and actually have rainfall.
All the, like I said,
all the other moons,
none of them really have
substantial atmospheres.
Some may be active.
[Inaudible] for example,
has active volcanology,
but it doesn't have an atmosphere.
So Titan's the only place that has
a cycle of evaporation, rainfall,
and liquids on the surface
where you really could just go,
if you had a spacesuit,
you could go and float
around on a boat on
the surface of Titan.
You could take, you could take a
voyage across one of its lakes.
And you know, so who knows what
the future holds for tourism.
In that respect.
This is one of my favorite
images of Titan here.
This was looking back
towards the sun.
and this shows you for real.
You can see the glint here
of the sun reflecting off one
of the, one of the lakes.
And I like to tie this
together with another world
that we're more familiar with.
Which is the Earth.
You can see that these two bodies,
like I said, are the only two places
in the solar system that actually
have liquids on the surface
in the form of lakes and seas.
So Titan and the Earth are in
some ways very distant cousins.
And the exciting thing about Titan
is because its atmosphere is,
has such great similarities to
the Earth but also differences.
For example, there's no oxygen.
There's no life that we can see.
But it may be similar to the
Earth several billion years ago
when the Earth had newly formed, and
its atmosphere was really different.
Before the rise of plants that
were able to breathe the oxygen
into the atmosphere
that we now have.
The atmosphere of the Earth
may have been much more filled
with carbon dioxide and methane.
And in fact so Titan may
be like a time machine
that we can go back a couple of
billion years to the early Earth
and see what would have been
happening in those processes.
Titan things have just
happened so much more slowly
because it's so much colder.
And further from the sun.
So now I want to come on to Saturn.
Of course this is our,
this is our main guy here
in the center of the Saturn system.
Such an amazing planet.
Many people's personal favorite
planet in terms of just the drama
of the, of the ring system.
And here, it's a shame we can't
have our [inaudible] lights
down a little bit.
But I hope you can see that there's
actually something going on here
on Saturn's Northern Hemisphere.
And this was in fact a huge
storm which erupted in 2010.
And Cassini was there
for a ringside,
literally a ringside seat
to see this going off.
And this storm erupted.
And these have been seen
in the past from the Earth,
but of course, much further away.
And this storm erupted,
and it gradually erupted all
the way around the planet.
We called this the Dragon Storm
because of its initial appearance.
And in fact eventually due to the
winds that gusted this material
so that it wrapped all
the way around the planet.
It was like the dragon's
head was eating its own tail.
And this was really phenomenal.
Cassini was able to watch this
unfold over several months.
Typically these storms occur
on Saturn about every 30 years.
This one came about ten years early.
So Cassini was very lucky to be
there for its, for its ringside seat
to see the storm going off.
You can see here as well the,
the sun is projecting the shadow
of the rings onto the planet.
So the sun would be slightly
off to the, to the North here,
projecting through the rings
and onto the planet here.
So as this storm erupted,
Cassini was able
to look using its different
cameras to look
into longer and longer wavelengths.
You can see here, as we
see longer wavelengths,
we can see deeper into
the atmosphere.
And in fact the, the
instrument that I work
on is the longer wavelength
infrared camera on Cassini.
And we look at heat.
And we were able to see that this
storm was glowing 100 degrees
brighter than the background
of Saturn.
So this was a huge warm spot.
And this was just throwing
off energy
that was visible to Cassini here.
So Saturn's North pole has even
more remarkable stories to tell.
If we, if we were able to look
right down on Saturn's North pole
as Cassini can, this
is what we would see.
And you see this remarkable
ship emerging here.
This was just glimpsed
by Voyager as it flew by.
But Cassini was able to really
show us the first picture looking
down on Saturn's North pole.
And this is what we call the
Hexagon for obvious reasons.
This is a wind jet which is
circling around Saturn's North pole.
You can see here in the center.
This is actually a hurricane eye
wall, something very topical.
This week, with all the drama
going on in the Caribbean Sea.
This hurricane on Saturn's
North pole,
this eye wall is many
times bigger than the ones
that we have on the Earth.
In fact, this circular
region here would take
up about the entire
Easter United States.
So this is, this is much bigger.
And this entire hexagon
shape is about twice,
two and a half times
the size of the Earth.
So this is really huge.
And, and the winds that are
going around here are the fastest
that are known in the, in
the entire solar system,
300 kilometers an hour.
So really fast wind jets here.
In fact, people in the Cassini
mission are still working
to unravel exactly how this
six-sided shape emerges.
But what we do know is this is
a jet stream which is similar
to the jet streams
we have on the Earth.
And as it, as it goes around the
pole, it wavers from side to side.
Creating this six-sided structure.
So let, let's take a
look at Saturn's rings.
Of course, these are one of the
most dramatic features of Saturn.
And here's a, a, a
primer to the rings.
You can see here the, the brightest,
thickest part of the ring's
what you call the B ring.
And that's sandwiched on either
side by the A and the C ring.
These were named a long time
ago by early astronomers.
There's a prominent gap
here, the Cassini Division,
that was discovered back
in the, the 1600s from some
of the earliest telescopes.
And you can see here,
there's another gap here,
an A ring called the
[inaudible] Gap.
And we now know that there are
in fact moons that are going
around inside the rings that
are carving out these channels.
And all the way down here, you
can see the innermost D ring,
a very faint ring which
stretches almost
down to the surface
of Saturn itself.
We'll talk about that
a little more later.
So here's a view of the moon Pan.
This is one of the close-up
views that we just got recently.
Going around inside that,
that [inaudible] Gap
which I just showed you.
And so as Pan goes around, it's able
to clear the material in the rings.
And you know Cassini's cameras have
for the first time been able to show
up close up what these
moons look like.
Another really fabulous view here.
You can see that these rings,
even though these are
almost incredibly thin,
just a few tens of yards thick.
Even though they're hundreds of
thousands of miles in diameter.
There are places where the
material gets disrupted
by the moons that are going around.
And throws off these clouds.
So you can see these sort
of pillars of material.
And you can actually see the shadows
that they're throwing
onto the rings here.
And these are being
thrown up for tens,
tens of kilometers above the rings.
And then they're casting
a shadow here.
You can see from the, from the sun.
So this is the outermost
edge of the main rings here.
This is the [inaudible] which I just
showed you which has the small moon,
Pan, going around in here.
And then right outside the
main rings, we have this ribbon
which we call the [inaudible].
And this ribbon is maintained
actually by a pair of moons which go
around either side, and we
call those the Shepherds.
So one is going around just
inside the, the [inaudible].
And the one on the
outside you can see,
actually this little guy right here.
And as they go around again, they're
able to, to cause some disruption
to the, to the [inaudible]
as they circle Saturn.
So when Cassini was, was
taking movies of the rings,
we were able to see even
more structure here.
You can see these,
we call these spokes
or these shadows or
spokes in the rings.
They look almost like the
spokes you have on a bicycle.
And these are dynamical
phenomena again which are caused
by [inaudible] from
the gravity of the,
of the various moons going around.
But there's a lot of
work still to be done
to understand exactly how
these disturbances occur.
Which cause these periodic thinning
and thickening of Saturn's rings.
So Cassini's remarkable
13-year mission is now coming
to its last few days.
So let's, let's go right up to
date and look at the activities
that are planned for
the end of the mission.
So during the solstice part of the
mission which was began in 2010.
And it's taken us up
to the present day.
This shows you the orbits which
Cassini has, has made of Saturn.
And Saturn of course
has its, has its rings.
And these are tipped over
by 27 degrees compared
to Saturn's path around the sun.
so Cassini has for most
of its time remained
in this same plane as the rings.
But of course if we, and that's
where the moons are, in fact.
So the Saturn system is
like a giant, you know,
it's like a giant saucer.
And many of the moons are going
around in the same
plane as the rings.
So to encounter those moons, Cassini
has to go around in that direction.
But to see the rings then of course
we have to change our orientation.
So then we tip our orbits
to go over Saturn's poles.
And then we can actually
look down and see the rings.
So over the last seven
years, these are the orbits
that Cassini has made around Saturn.
You can see right in the middle
here, periodically going from the,
the equatorial orbits
to the polar orbits
so that we can see different things.
And changing our, changing
our path each time
to encounter many of
these distant moons.
A lot of these orbits
were redesigned
after we discovered
those remarkable jets
or geysers coming out of Enceladus.
So that we could go
back for another look
and another look and another look.
And eventually we went by 22 times.
Just to, just to keep looking
and to sample the material
in different ways.
And here highlighted in yellow, you
can see these are the final orbits.
So when we first arrived at Saturn,
we stayed well away from the rings
because these rings are chips of ice
mostly that are circulating around.
But who knows the damage they could
do to the spacecraft if we flew
through the rings at you
know ten miles per second.
This could cause a lot of
damage to the spacecraft.
But as the mission is drawing
to a close, we've really decided
to go for, go for broke and
do, do more dramatic things.
So the first maneuver that
we did starting in December
of last year was to take our
innermost orbit much closer
to Saturn than we'd
ever gone before.
In fact, just to graze the very
outer edges of the main rings.
And in fact to go right
by this F ring,
the one that I just
showed you like a ribbon.
And to take a really close look up
at the F ring and the moons there.
And that took us through
to April of this year.
And then beginning in April, for
the last five months of the mission,
we decided to do something
even more dramatic.
Which was to take a dive right
between the innermost ring
and the planet itself.
And this is a gap just a couple
thousand kilometers wide.
And these are what we call our
proximal orbits Cassini [inaudible].
And it's coming up to
its 22nd orbit right now.
And these are just
six-day-long orbits.
So you can see here again,
we had these what we called the
ring-grazing orbits where we went
around and grazed the outside of the
F ring and went around from December
of last year through to April.
And then we did an
encounter again with Titan.
Titan's what we frequently
use to give us a little kick,
like a little change
in our trajectory.
And then to come into
these really dramatic,
what we call proximal orbits,
actually diving through the gap
between the planet
and the rings itself.
And originally, we were planning
to do maybe a dozen of these.
But then we thought, "Well, how many
can we squeeze out of it, right?"
We don't want this to end.
So we went up to 15 and then 18
and then finally the mission
chief engineer said, "Okay,
you can have 22 and that's it.
That, that's really the limit."
Your, our fuel tank is, is
well into the empty zone.
Where our "check fuel" light is on.
We're down to less than
three percent of our fuel.
The margin of error is five percent.
So. So, we're really running on
fumes right now, but we're confident
that we can just finish,
finish the mission out.
So you can see here in close up
just how dramatic it is diving
through this gap between
this innermost,
there's a faint D ring
here which stretches down.
And then just a couple of thousand
kilometers where it empties out.
And in fact, it's not even
really ever completely empty.
So in fact, those innermost ring
particles, as they get closer
and closer to Saturn, and then
receive the reflected sunlight off
Saturn, they actually
begin to melt and turn
into just water vapor or mist.
So Cassini's diving through
a cloud of mist as it goes
through this gap every time.
It's really like going through
a car wash every time it goes
through this gap.
And at the start we were using our
main dish antennae as a protective,
almost like a bulldozer
to go in front of us
as we went through the, the rings.
But as we were got more confidence
that this material's not going
to damage us, we were able
to turn the spacecraft
and do different pictures which I'll
show you as we, as we went through.
So here you can see
this is the surface
of Saturn here at the bottom.
And then as you go outwards
you go through the rings.
So this shows you all the
way out through the rings.
These were the orbits that
started in December of 2016.
You can see each one of these little
blue dots indicating how close we
went to the outer rings.
And you can see, here's
the F ring here.
And then all the way, and
then starting in April 22nd,
we did our, our kick with Titan.
And we flung Cassini
right into this gap.
And you can see we
jumped right down here.
So we're now right down, right
above the surface of Titan,
or of Saturn just dramatically
doing these 22 orbits here.
And you can see this, this last
one here doesn't look too good
because this is a, this
is inside the atmosphere.
And that's coming up
really, really soon.
So I want to show you some of
the, some of the latest images
that we have during these last
few months of the mission.
Here is a tiny little moon, Daphnis,
shown here for the first time making
waves as it passes through one
of these little narrow
tracks that it's making.
You know, the [inaudible] gap
in the outer edge of the A ring.
Someone had a great meme online,
if you go and look it up that says,
you know, "You know,
you may be small,
but you can still make waves."
And it is a really,
really great meme.
You can go look it up online.
So Daphnis doesn't care that
it's tiny compared to Saturn.
It's still making itself,
its presence known.
And here you can see February 2017
as we were doing our,
our F ring orbits.
One of the first looks-down
on the North pole of Saturn
as it emerged finally in the
sunlight for the first time.
This had been in darkness
during the start of the mission.
But we were finally able
to look on in full color.
You can see this hexagon shape
here which I mentioned here.
This is 20,000 miles
across, and in the center,
we have this really remarkable,
glowing-blue hurricane system here
which is 1000 miles across.
And one of the fascinating things
is that this, this hurricane
on Saturn's North pole has
actually changed color.
You can see here back in June of
2013, the entire region looked,
had a bluish tinge to it.
While the center was more of
a, of a greeny-orange color.
And then this is reversed.
So this shows us that the action of,
of sunlight is actually
changing the, the,
the particles in the atmosphere.
And causing them to,
ultraviolet light
from the sun is causing
them to change color.
Here's a look at Titan
from May of this year.
One of the things that
we've been looking
for as Titan's North
pole went into summer was
that there'd be more
evaporation, right?
So the sunlight hits
these methane lakes
and there'd be more evaporation.
We'd start to see clouds
forming and, and rain.
And it took a long time.
Titan kept us waiting, but
finally in May of 2017,
we were able to see these
really dramatic clouds streaking
around Saturn's North pole.
Here you can see these lakes, these
methane-rich lakes on the surface.
And these clouds, these are
methane clouds which are going
to rain methane back
down on the surface.
And just when we thought that
Cassini has no more surprises,
that we'd been in orbit
for 13 years,
what is there left to discover?
We've seen the plumes of Enceladus,
we got a close look up at some
of these tiny innermost
ring, ring moons of Saturn.
And low and behold, they
look like pieces of pasta.
I mean, take your pick
tortellini or flying saucer.
And so these moons which are
just you know ten miles across,
have this remarkable shape.
In fact, they look almost like
a miniature Saturn, right?
They have their, their
own, it looks like they're,
they've got their own little
flattened ring around them.
But this is, is, is stuck on.
This is, it's almost like
a tutu skirt you know
that you would have that's
stuck on to these moons.
And it's, it's maybe a
couple of hundred yards,
couple hundred meters
in, in thickness.
So it's quite, quite
strong, quite stable.
And this is a coalesced material.
So it's [inaudible]
or a collected ring,
ring chips [inaudible] collected
around the equator
of these small moons.
They've just all coalesced
and stuck together
and you know melted and refrozen.
And formed this almost like
a solid ring around it.
So nobody had predicted
this at all until,
until we were able
to take these images.
So really unbelievable.
So what I have here is a,
a little, short movie clip.
This was taken back in April
when we did our first close dive
over the North pole of Saturn
and our first dive going right
down over Saturn and down
to the, down to the rings.
And the cameras were
turned towards Saturn.
So Cassini was basically taking
a, taking an image strip looking
over the North pole and
coming down and down.
And then right before
we got to the rings,
we had to turn our cameras away
so that we could put our antennae
in the forward direction as
we passed through the rings
for the first time for safety.
So we go almost to the
equator and then stop.
So let me show you this,
this movie clip here.
So this is Cassini flying
over the north pole of Saturn.
You can see here, here's the,
this hurricane eye wall storm.
These images are all
in black and white.
You can see these other little
storm vortices as we passed on.
Over the hexagon, over the outer
rim of the hexagon, and then begin
to go down across the plane.
You can see here we're going over
these, these streaks through the -
all the way to the hexagon are going
down over the Northern Hemisphere.
And these were at the
time the closest images
that had ever been taken of Saturn.
So we're going from about 40,000
miles away at the North pole
down to just about 4000 miles.
As we come right down, you
can see all the structure
of Saturn's storms here.
And the image track gets
narrower and narrower
as it gets on towards the bottom.
So even more, more than nine years
after the mission was originally
designed to finish back in 2008,
Cassini was still giving
us first of a kind science.
It was almost like having a
new mission all over again.
So you can see here.
So here something even more
fantastic in many ways.
This is looking at the rings
from the inside looking
outwards across the rings.
So this was taken on August 20th.
Cassini for the first time actually
kept its cameras going all the way
through as a dive between the rings.
And it turned its cameras outwards,
and what you see here
is looking at the rings.
And then as they go
thinner and thinner,
you're actually just
looking at the ring's edge
on from the inside looking out.
This is a place that no spacecraft
had ever ventured before Cassini
did it.
And the fact that we are able
to do this seems you
know almost miraculous.
That spacecraft is still surviving,
still returning these
miraculous images.
So just some of the amazing
facts and figures here.
You can look up online for
Cassini's Grand Finale.
So I'm, I'm almost finished.
I want to just show you
a couple of fun cartoons.
And I'm going to finish
with a short video sequence,
and then I'll take your questions.
So many people have been really
motivated by the Cassini mission.
In fact, if you go online and
look on, on, on the web and look
on Facebook and Twitter
and all these social media
[inaudible] you'll see some
of the imagery.
People have done their own artwork.
They've done cartoons,
and this is one
of the fun cartoons
that came up online.
So Saturn's saying, "Hey, Cassini,
I hear you're retiring
in September 2017.
Congrats! How do you
want to celebrate?
Maybe do lunch with me and
my moons or something?"
And Cassini says, "No, I'll
just go barreling straight
into your atmosphere,
learning as much as I'm,
as I can before I'm crushed
to death and vaporized
in a spectacular whirling
inferno beneath your mysterious
stormy clouds,"
[ Laughter ]
It was like, are you for real?
It's like, whoa!
That's awesome.
So you know, no, no
retirement for Cassini.
He's going to keep working
right up to the end.
So back in the springtime,
the jet propulsion laboratory
out in California,
one of the branches
of NASA created a really
nice video sequence
which I want to show you here.
It's a bit of a tear-jerker.
People were, there was, when it was
shown to the mission scientists,
there wasn't a dry eye in the house.
So I'm going to show
that to you right now.
This is just a few
minutes in length.
And I hope you'll have
sound as well.
[ Music ]
>> A lone explorer on a
mission to reveal the grandeur
of Saturn, its rings and moons.
[ Music ]
After 20 years in space,
NASA's Cassini space probe
is running out of fuel.
And so to protect the
moons of Saturn
that could have conditions
suitable for life,
a spectacular end has been planned
for this long-lived
traveler from Earth.
[ Music ]
>> Five, four, three, two, one.
And liftoff of the
Cassini spacecraft
on a [inaudible] to Saturn.
[ Inaudible ]
>> In 2004, following a seven-year
journey through the solar system,
Cassini arrived at Saturn.
[ Inaudible ]
The spacecraft carried a passenger,
the European Huygens probe,
the first human-made
object to land on a world
in the distant outer solar system.
For over a decade, Cassini has
shared the wonders of Saturn
and its family of icy moons.
Taking us to astounding worlds where
methane rivers run to a methane sea.
Where jets of ice and gas are
blasting material into space
from the liquid water ocean
that might harbor the
ingredients for life.
And Saturn, a journey
[inaudible] ruled by raging storms
and delicate harmonies of gravity.
[ Music ]
Now Cassini has one
last daring assignment.
[ Music ]
Cassini's grand finale
is a brand-new adventure.
Twenty-two dives through the space
between Saturn and its rings.
As it repeatedly braves
this unexplored region,
Cassini seeks new insights about the
origins of the rings and the nature
of the planet's interior, closer
to Saturn than ever before.
[ Music ]
On the final orbit, Cassini
will plunge into Saturn,
fighting to keep its
antennae pointed at Earth
as it transmits its farewell.
In the skies of Saturn,
the journey ends.
As Cassini becomes part
of the planet itself.
[ Music ]
>> So there you go.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus: That was grand.
We can take questions now.
And if you would repeat the question
so that everyone can hear it.
>> Conor Nixon: Of course.
>> Stephanie Marcus: And anybody
who has to leave, too bad.
>> Conor Nixon: And, and please
take the materials outside.
There's some stickers and bookmarks
and things from the Cassini project.
So you're welcome
>> Stephanie Marcus: Help
yourselves and take for friends.
>> Conor Nixon: Okay?
[ Inaudible Question ]
So Saturn really is,
is all atmosphere.
It doesn't have a surface the way
what we call the inner planets
like Venus and Earth
and Mars have a surface.
So the atmosphere,
it's like Jupiter.
It's a big ball of gas
unless you go deeper
and deeper into the atmosphere.
The gas would eventually
turn into a liquid.
And then right in the
center we believe that it's,
it's got some weird state of
hydrogen where it's like a metal,
and then there's probably
some rock in the very center.
But this storm, it, it,
it comes from deep within.
We don't know the mechanism
right now that's creating it.
But like I said, every 30 years
or so there's enough energy
that gets stored inside.
One of the theories
is that it's energy
that is trapped by water clouds.
And eventually, this
energy gets stored inside
until eventually it erupts.
And it breaks through the clouds
that have been trapping
the energy inside.
And then it erupts and
creates this giant storm.
Then it all begins again.
The clouds, the deep
water clouds reform,
and they trap the heat inside again.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Okay, so the question
was about the [inaudible]
and there's two parts
to the question.
And Cassini's a plutonium
radioactively-powered spacecraft.
Do we have enough plutonium being
produced for future missions?
And the second part
was how do we feel
about the plutonium being
deposited into Saturn.
So you know, for the first
part of the question,
traditionally NASA spacecraft
into the outer solar system
have all been nuclear powered.
The Voyager spacecraft,
nuclear powered.
Both Galileo mission
to Jupiter in the '90s
and Cassini were nuclear powered.
So they have a few tens
of kilograms of plutonium
which are generating heat.
And this generates electricity.
As far as future missions goes,
right now there's a debate
about how much do we
need, plutonium?
And one of the things is [inaudible]
improvements in solar technology.
It's [inaudible] for
some of the applications
that we've formerly used plutonium
we're now ambitious enough to think
that we can use solar power.
So in fact the next mission
that's going back to Jupiter,
the [inaudible] is actually
designed to use solar panels.
Very, very large and highly
efficient new generation solar
panels instead of plutonium.
But for other applications,
we still need plutonium.
So in fact the Rover, which is
on Mars right now there's
this Rover Curiosity,
originally called the Mars Science
Laboratory which is about the size
of a small car that's
trucking around on the surface
of Gale Crater trucking
up a mountain.
That is nuclear powered,
and you couldn't imagine
having big enough solar panels
that would do that, do that mission.
The previous smaller
Rovers, of course,
Spirit and Opportunity
were solar powered.
But for missions, for
example, some of the missions
that have been proposed have been,
"Let's actually go float a boat
on the surface of one
of these Titan lakes."
Now at that level, you're
so far down in the clouds
that you're not going to
get enough solar energy.
Especially not with a small object
that can't deploy big solar panels.
There's even been ideas, in fact
there's a mission just been proposed
to NASA for one of its
recent competitions
that would fly a helicopter on
Titan, actually a quadcopter
that would be again, about
the size of a small car
and this is nuclear powered.
So we do need the plutonium
for those missions.
As far as Cassini's plutonium going
into Saturn, you know, Saturn is,
you know, it's 80 times the,
the, the mass of the Earth.
The plutonium and radioactive
elements that are
on the Earth are just a
small part of the Earth.
So this is just going to be you
know a few atoms amongst trillions
and trillions of atoms.
It's not going to make any
difference to Saturn itself.
Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, at the back of the room?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Right, so the question was
any fear that the boats
or other missions we propose would
contaminate with organic material?
So in fact, NASA has someone down
in NASA headquarters really close
to here on the south side
of the mall whose job is
called Planetary Protection.
And it's not just protecting
the Earth from asteroids.
It's actually protecting
the other planets from us.
And missions now that go, go out
to Mars and to the other planets,
our whole view has changed compared
to what we were doing in the 1970s.
Instead of just sending things
out there, we're now very rigorous
about not wanting to, not send
little gift packages from the Earth
of microbes or bacteria which
then might colonize another
pristine environment.
And then we wouldn't find
out what we're trying to find
out which is has life
evolved there itself?
Is it different from the Earth?
You know, if we go there and
find a bunch of Earth microbes,
that's not going to be helpful.
In fact, that's the reason why
the Cassini mission is plunging
into Saturn.
It's to protect some of
the moons from anything
that might still be
remaining on Cassini,
any microbes that might still have
somehow miraculously survived this
20-year mission.
We don't want to have Cassini
crash into Enceladus or Titan
where there might be, there
might be something going on.
And future missions, we're going
to take [inaudible] protections.
So those missions that have been
proposed, there was a boat proposed
for Titan a few years ago.
The quadcopter, as I
mentioned, those will have
to undergo a very rigorous
[inaudible] protection.
There's also a study underway right
now for a, a mission that might land
on Europa, which is
one of Jupiter's moons.
Which also almost certainly
has an ocean inside.
And that would land, maybe
drill, take some ice cores.
And that's going to have very, very
rigorous planetary protection on it.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yeah, I wish I could
- so the question was,
is the yellow color
of Titan for real?
And I wish I could have spent
more time talking about Titan's,
it's actually my favorite
object in the solar system.
It's what I do most
of my own research on.
Because it's, it's, it appears
just like this orange ball.
In fact, if you were to look through
a telescope from, from the Earth.
If you had a decent
size backyard telescope,
maybe a 12-inch telescope, you could
actually see this little orange dot
right beside Saturn.
And, so it is orange.
It's really orange.
In fact, this is what
really confounded scientists
for literally centuries.
So when Titan was first discovered,
it was called Titan for a reason.
And it's because it was
thought to be the biggest moon.
And it turns out it was
playing tricks on us.
It's not the biggest moon.
It's because it's got a big,
puffed-up atmosphere which is -
it actually stretches about 1000
kilometers away from the surface.
Because it's got a low gravity, the
atmosphere can, can stretch out.
But the, the orange cloud
layers that we see are two
or three hundred miles
above the actual surface.
So when scientists measured the
size of this dot, they got it wrong
because they weren't
seeing the surface.
And it wasn't until the Voyager
spacecraft went by in 1980.
It used its radio dish to send
back a signal to the Earth.
And as we watched for when that
signal got blocked by the surface,
we were finally able to
determine the true size of Titan.
And it's just slightly smaller
than one of Jupiter's moons,
Ganymede, by about 70 kilometers.
But it's really close to - you know,
and that's why it's called Titan.
But the, the orange color is
produced by the action of sunlight
on its atmosphere which is methane.
And as the sunlight strikes
the methane, it breaks up the,
the molecule which is
carbon and hydrogen,
and is reassembles it into chains.
And these chains form
these smog materials.
And the smog is the orange
material that we see.
There's a little bit of
nitrogen mixed in there as well.
So actually the atmosphere
would be pretty poisonous.
It's got a lot of carbon,
nitrogen molecules
in there which we call cyanides.
And those are not healthy
things to be ingesting.
So you've got a, you've got a
waft of, of [inaudible] probably
if you were down on
the surface of Titan.
So it, the orange smog is
the, is the atmosphere.
And it really is an
orange color, yeah.
[ Inaudible Question ]
That's a really great question.
So the question is isn't Enceladus
the only moon that's shooting
geysers out into space?
Also are they only shooting
out of these four cracks?
So back in 1989 when
Voyager II flew by Neptune,
it was able to see some geysers
on one of Neptune's moons, Triton.
These are much smaller in size than
what's going on with Enceladus.
But we were able to see
some, some vents on Triton.
More recently there's been
a lot of attention focused
on Europa, moon of Jupiter.
And even though we had a
spacecraft there in the '90s
and early 2000s called Galileo,
the spacecraft had some technical
problems, and it wasn't able to get
as much data back as
we'd originally hoped.
The environment around
Jupiter's actually very,
very harsh radiation environment.
It really, it really just chewed
up that spacecraft really quickly.
But since then in the last couple of
years, there's been some indications
that there may be similar plumes
coming from, from Europa actually.
Which is a similar
moon to, to Enceladus.
Although it's about
seven times wider.
Right now those observations viewed
with the Hubble Telescope
really tenuous.
You know, we're just seeing
maybe, just a hint of something.
So we're really not sure.
There's actually a lot of telescopes
observing Europa right now to try
and find out if there's, if we can
get a better detection of that.
But Enceladus is really unique
in the sense that it is small,
and it's got these
really dramatic jets
which we can just see every
time we fly by Enceladus.
We can see these jets.
They appear to be coming
predominantly
out of these four cracks.
But the curious thing is
that there's other cracks
around Enceladus in other parts
that are not active today.
So what we think is
that maybe in the past,
the moon just kind of flipped over.
So maybe the south pole was,
you know is now the equator,
and the equator's now
the south pole.
So there were cracks
before that were active.
But then as the moon has turned on
its side, it's created new cracks.
And the old ones have,
have closed up.
So we can see cracks
all over the surface
that may have been
active in the past.
But right now it's the ones on
the south pole that appear to be
where all the energy
is concentrated.
Okay, question here?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Another good question.
The question is what have we learned
about the formation
of Saturn's rings?
So Saturn you know originally we
thought Saturn was the only one
of the four planets that had
rings because they're so dramatic
and so obvious from Earth.
Like I said, you can look
with a backyard telescope
and you can see Saturn's rings.
And it's a wonderful thing to do.
But as the voyager
spacecraft went out,
they found that actually
Jupiter, Uranus,
and Neptune all have
very, very faint rings.
But their rings are different.
Their rings are, are dark material.
They're like dust rings.
Where Saturn's rings are
bright, icy, and they're big.
So there's several theories.
It appears that Saturn's
rings are young.
And that's why they're still there
because they're not really stable.
Over many hundreds
of millions of years,
they would eventually
either evaporate.
Or they would spiral inwards to
the planet and they would go away.
It may be that Jupiter, the rings
that we see of Jupiter and Neptune
and Uranus, those faint,
dusty rings leftover.
Those may be kind of remnants
of rings that were more big
and bright and icy in the past.
That have just left kind
of a faint trace now.
There's theories that maybe Saturn's
rings were created fairly recently
by the, by the breakup
of a satellite.
So it may be that there were,
there were more satellites
than we see today.
And two of them, you know,
they banged into each other.
Broke up, and just stretched this
debris ring which has been stable
for maybe tens of millions of years
or hundreds of millions of years.
But probably not going all
the way back billions of years
to the start of the solar system.
So it may be a transient phenomenon
that we're just seeing
this ring now.
And if we were around in another,
you know, few hundred million years,
you know, they wouldn't be there.
So, so that's, that's
one of the theories.
But one of the, one of the many
scientific things Cassini's doing
right now, this dive between the
[inaudible] rings is not just purely
to get some great pictures.
Actually, we can measure
the deflection
of the spacecraft by the gravity.
Not only the planet's but by the
gravity of the ring material.
So we can use that to
actually weigh the rings.
And get a better estimate of how
much mass of material's in there.
And that's going to give us a better
estimate as to how young they are.
So that, that's, that's just going
on right now, you know, as we speak.
Exciting.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Do
you have any idea what time
of day the demise is going to be?
>> Conor Nixon: Yes, thank
you for reminding me of that.
So next Friday, it will be
just before 8 a.m. I believe
on the East Coast.
It will be just before 5
a.m. out in California,
where I'll be out at the
jet propulsion laboratory.
The signal from Cassini takes about
83 minutes to get back at the speed
of light back to the Earth.
So the times that we're recording is
the time the signal is at the Earth.
.The spacecraft, when the
signal stops on the Earth,
the spacecraft will have
died 83 minutes earlier.
So what Cassini's going to
do is it's going to keep its,
its main antennae pointed to the
Earth for as long as possible.
And you saw like right at the
end there when it's fighting
with the thrusters to try and
keep its altitude control,
it's going to try to keep its
antennae pointed to the Earth.
As long as possible.
Eventually the atmosphere is going
to be dense enough that it's going
to cause the spacecraft to tumble.
And then it will lose
altitude control.
That's when the signal will be lost.
And then a few tens of seconds
after that, it's just going to be
like a meteorite or a meteor.
It's just going to - pieces
are going to start flying off.
And it's going to,
it's going to burn
up 30,000 miles an hour
in Saturn's atmosphere.
>> Stephanie Marcus: You'll
probably have to have a wake, right?
>> Conor Nixon: We have
several events planned, yeah.
For next, next Friday, yeah.
Everybody's going to be getting
up really early in California.
They'll go down to - California's
[inaudible] Technology's hosting a
big event for about 4000 people.
Everybody's who's ever worked on
the mission's going to show up.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Stephanie Marcus: Well,
I guess we should end
and get out of the room.
[Applause]
>> Conor Nixon: Yes.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.com.